Tony DuShane, Writer/Podcaster/Teacher:
Storytelling is my religion. It's so it's
nothing I will ever (if there are Gods
of storytelling), I’m never going to
go against the Gods of storytelling so…
Film Courage: What mistakes do
writers make when writing characters?
Tony DuShane: I don't know if they make
mistakes writing characters well maybe they do?
It's just find ways to make them three-dimensional
and there's always ways and I think that's when
in the end your we need to know what
the character's goal is and then just
make it harder for them, that's
about it. For the most part it's
I think I do find some people are…then this is one
that comes “Oh no, this is based on a true story
and no this is a real person,” and it's just like
Okay, but get back to the get back to the page.
Stop doing the verbatim on you know but I also
think that's a technique that technique that's
a very great word for it's a way for people
to avoid actually writing it's a way for them
to avoid actually sinking into the conflict of
the possibilities of that character so they can
just say oh no this really happened and it's just
like you just don't want to go there that's okay
don't be a writer it's not a it's it's not a
hugely paying gig unless it is sometimes it's
it's mostly sad you know it's it only looks
pretty in movies so why wouldn't where would
they not want to go I mean I find this I find
this a lot and I find this in the majority of
you know maybe 70 percent of the students that
take my classes they they don't want to they
it's like when we were talking about
the the evilness and the darkness
I don't think they want to go into the darkness
of their characters because they're too scared
to show the darkness of themselves and that's
when we're gonna completely that's that's just
when the the the cat the sand castle of the
story you're creating just won't work it's
you need to know the imperfections that's
that's the it's the fun part you know
right so they make this character
too perfect or or it's too flat
yeah too flat and just it doesn't yeah it's
just it's reading like they're avoiding
and usually i'll ask them what they're avoiding
and oh no no this really happened and there's
people there's a lot of students who just don't
want notes and you just kind of find them and go
all right well you're not getting notes
then it's just like oh you know what
my standard is oh well thanks for sending this
in and you know just sprinkle more conflict
if a student's getting that note from me that
means that I realize they're not taking any
notes and they just want a participation grade so
so if I let's suppose I turn something in and and
you you give me a first pass of first round of
notes and then you see that I don't integrate
or I don't change anything does that mean i'm not
receptive no it's it usually you know I don't mind
I don't mind if a student's confused I don't
mind if a student is is even offended and
like whoa wait a second but the the cut then
the conversation let's have the conversation
and and it doesn't mean that they need to become
take every note and become great you know in the
next scenes but but you could start to tell you
know after a few workshops where you're just like
it's just it just happens or the the practice
is happening it's just like oh you're hitting it
you're hitting it you're hitting that conflict
you're you're hitting this i'm seeing what
you're doing here and here and here you can
just you could tell when someone's avoiding
truth almost and when someone just
and that and that's what that's the
one thing that I really kind of preach
to every writing class that I teach is
write your truth I can give you an outline
with 90 I can give you 90 story beats
with the character with the all the plot and
everything I can give it to every one of you
and tell you to go write it and you're all
going to come back with completely different
screenplays because you're gonna come
with exactly who you are how you grew up
your tragedies your victories you know you you
have the fingerprint and that's the beauty of
being a writer it's like people get so stuck on
ideas oh that's a good idea it's like it doesn't
the idea doesn't matter it's your fingerprint
on how the story how you're telling the story
because every story's been told you know they may
pretend like oh we got this new thing that we did
it like this and it's just like all right but in
the end it's still a heist movie or in the end
it's still a love story that you know you found a
little different angle on but they're the core of
it the core that we care about is still in there
so that then that will that'll never go away and
that's when I even say hey if you're lucky enough
to get on an adam sandler movie and you know adam
sandler writes goofy movies but if you're lucky
enough to get a project on that put your truth
in there big go ahead and be goofy but put an
element of your truth in there and that will
make you stand above and they'll be like then when
they read it they'll be like you know what I don't
know why I like this but I like it and that's when
we're putting our own truth into the work and we
don't have to totally spell it out but that's
when people go I connect to this and I don't
know exactly why or how but usually that means the
writer the writer has brought in just utter truth
and honesty and storytelling do you find people
are sometimes scared because you're so honest
it intimidates them because then that
means they have to meet you at that level
probably I should probably be less intimidating
well not intentionally but but I mean this is who
you are and you want to yeah and I don't expect I
mean I don't expect everyone to have to you know
deal with the my demons the way I deal with them
yeah there's it's you know I can tell when there's
avoidance in a sci-fi you know it's the
alien isn't looking at themselves like
yeah yeah the alien looks at himself in the
mirror and says i'm gorgeous and green yeah
there's there's just there's it's just interesting
because I think and I didn't even realize this but
i've read so much work that I can really tell
fast if if they if they're into it and if they
it and if they had a stake in
writing it there's this with
and I don't know exactly what it is and I
don't know how to explain it but I could
read five pages of something and realize if
if they're invested and this is important
or if this is an exercise and they're trying
to and they're just trying to sell something
which could just be selling the teacher for a
good grade or yeah yeah yeah okay or even scripts
that are given to me going hey can you you know
can you do a read through on this and give and
give me some pages of coverage and i'm like yeah
and i'll be like sometimes i've given back scripts
after 10 pages and i'll be like you didn't do the
work yet so it's just you know and then they're
I there's something I have with with
writing is I kind of can't I have a problem
sugarcoating it sometimes but but but storytelling
is my religion it's so it's nothing I will ever
if there are gods of storytelling i'm
never going to go against the gods of
storytelling so I hate it when someone asks
me oh did you like my book and i'm just like
you know I would never ask that of anybody I don't
even expect anyone to read anything I you know but
if someone says that I kind of have to either
tell them the truth or avoid it in some way
and sometimes I might might say you know
it was great to see you on that publisher
or I really liked that you got to work
with that editor and all they hear is
great and like they don't hear that I didn't say
anything about the book but I have to kind of
I can't say a book's greater a screenplay is great
if I feel on my bones it's not and I might be a
jerk because of that I don't know well also too
sometimes if you're going on a junket or press
junket you don't always have time to do I mean
you sometimes get this stuff last minute so you
don't always have time to read something or even
get a screener but but you know I mean sometimes
it's not just the work it's also the person
that did the work and that's fascinating too
oh exactly oh I totally agree I agree beyond
belief there's I mean that that the person
behind the work intrigues me I think i'm talking
about my friends when my friends come up to me
and we'll ask that and that throws me off but like
when I interview like every once every like 15
to 20 people will ask and that's I kind of have
to I have to rest I have to re-steer it because
I because when I do interviews i'm there to have
the conversation with the person i'm not there to
if we discuss storytelling great if you know but
I'd rather I'd rather not go into the details of
the character of the book because that's for other
you know that's for the other shows I guess yeah
or the question I love how was it to work with so
and so there was such a big name you know that's
like one of the I hear these journalists will ask
that in junkets and different things and sometimes
it's like well you're in a sense insulting the
person but hey that's just my my thing is I always
ask were they not were they were they nice to
work with okay and it's really fun to hear because
and then you know I f I was yeah I was on a set
and right before covid and someone was telling
me about one of my favorite stars and I was
like how was he to work with and they were like
he was nice above the line but below the line he
was not a good person to people and I was like
that's that's you know I don't want to
hear that yeah and plus you don't know
what the person's going through but I get it I
guess if you hear enough stories but sometimes
you don't you know there's a few people that
i've heard were difficult and then i've seen
someone come up and insist on a photo and
different things in a really rude way held it
really well and I was like wow they they actually
you know so you sometimes you just never know
you need to know the audience that's telling
you that if it's someone that's been working
in film for 20 years and they're working on film
after film after tv show after tv show i'll take
i'll take notice when they you know but
everyone knows everyone has a bad day
sure sure I assume everyone has a bad day so I
never yeah if someone was like oh I met someone
on the street and he was a jerk I just kind
of look at him and go I yeah I don't care.
What did you like about this video?